Living well doesn't have to cost an arm and a leg.
And cheap doesn't have to look it.
You will need very little.
Step one: Find a free or low-cost place to live.
Search online for house sitting positions both seasonal,...
...such as for beach and ski houses, and full-time as a caretaker.
Step two: Buy your clothes and furnishings at thrift stores.
If you check them out frequently, you'll find great stuff.
Keep an eye out for bargains with resale value,...
...like kitchen appliances that you can flip online after a little repair.
Step three: Eat only what's in season.
It's plentiful and cheap.
Plan meals around what's on sale, clip coupons...
...and use foods that give you more nutritional bang for your buck, like beans.
One week a month, forego grocery shopping...
...and just focus on finishing what's in your fridge and cupboards.
You'll be amazed how much this will save you.
Step four: Drink mostly tap water.
You'll be richer and healthier.
Step five: Whenever possible, walk or bike to your destination.
Get rid of your car if you can.
Bonus, if you do this, you won't need a gym membership.
Did you know?
Research shows that most millionaires live well below their means.